Hello everyone, this
is Dr. Carl Abraham
from the Jonesboro
campus presenting this
lecture on emerging
blood-borne pathogens.
The principles today are to
review the epidemiologics,
virulence factors, and
clinical presentations
of emerging blood-borne
pathogens, and to review
the diagnostic techniques
and treatments for them.
We're going to compare and
contrast these diseases
caused by different species
of single genuses, for
example, Bartonella, Plasmodium,
and Leishmania species.
I've included a QR code that
goes to the ScholarRxBrick
for protozoa and
ectoparasites on this slide.
Let's review a few key
concepts that will be
important during this
lecture. A zoonosis is a
human disease derived
from an animal reservoir.
A vector is a living
organism, typically
an arthropod, that transmits an
infection from one
host to another.
A life cycle is the
phases of growth and
transmission that
result in maturity and
reproduction of an
organism, often requiring
intermediate and
definitive hosts. hosts.
And infestation is the
term we use for the
presence of parasites
or ectoparasites on the
body's surface. We don't
use the term infection.
Started with our first
organism. There are many
Bartonella species that
cause human disease,
but we are going to look
at just three of them.
Bartonella henselae,
Quintana, and Bacilliformis.
These are pleomorphic
gram-negative rods.
Pleomorphic means the
shape of the bacteria can
vary, as opposed to the
uniform shape of, for example,
E. coli or Klebsiella
when seen on Gram stain.
Bartonella are catalase
and oxidase negative. They
infect CD34 cells that
are the progenitors of
endothelial cells, as well
as erythrocytes, resulting
in dissemination throughout
the endovasculature,
spread to the lymphatics,
lymph nodes, and rarely
organs such as the heart,
liver, spleen, and bone.
Bartonella grow very slowly
in culture, taking up to
two to six weeks, and they
are not well visualized
on gram stain. They are
well visualized using the
Worthing Starry Silver
Stain, an example of which is
shown on the bottom
right, the darkly staining
Bartonella organisms seen in
the center of the picture.
Hensley is the etiologic
agent of cat scratch disease.
It also causes bacillary
angiomatosis and Bartonella
peleiosis. It is geographically
distributed worldwide.
There are about 25,000
cases annually in the U.S.
It is transmitted by
cat fleas by a cat
scratch or bite. After
a 3-5 day incubation
period, a small red
papule, vesicle, or
nodule appears at the
site of inoculation.
That is followed by regional
lymphadenopathy,
fever, and malaise.
This is usually a self
-limited illness in those
who are immune-competent.
Very rarely, it can
go on to cause culture
-negative endocarditis,
fever of unknown origin,
and neuroretinitis.
Bartonella pelliosis is
a condition of the liver
or spleen in which
endothelial proliferation
results in enlarged
capillaries forming saccules
within these organs. It
is sometimes noted only
incidentally on imaging,
but it can help to suggest
the diagnosis in the
right clinical setting.
Many patients with
self-limited disease do
not even report to a
healthcare provider to get
a diagnosis and treatment,
but the diagnosis
can be made by PCR,
biopsy of skin lesions,
lymph nodes, or
affected organs that
show stellate
necrotizing granulomas.
The diagnosis can
also be made by
serum antibodies
or blood cultures.
Of note, blood
cultures need to be
held for many weeks
due to slow growth.
Treatment, if needed, is with
azithromycin or doxycycline.
and treatment is
always indicated in
immune-suppressed
persons who can have
extremely severe
or fatal disease.
Bartonella quintana causes
trench fever and bacillary
angiomatosis. It is so
named because soldiers in
World War II fighting in
trenches were widely infected.
It occurs worldwide, mostly
in settings of poverty,
overcrowding, and in those
experiencing homelessness.
It is transmitted by
the feces of body lice.
Symptoms are unique for
Quentin fever, a fever
that recurs every five
days, although this exact
pattern is not seen in
all patients, that is
accompanied by rash,
headache, back and leg pain.
These symptoms may abate and
then relapse after
days or weeks.
Bartonella Quintana
can also rarely
cause culture
-negative endocarditis.
Diagnosis is by PCR, blood or
tissue culture, or serology.
The prognosis is usually
quite good after prolonged
treatment with doxycycline
and gentamicin.
Bacillary angiomatosis,
caused by either Bartonella
henselae or quintana,
usually requires treatment
with long-term erythromycin
or doxycycline.
The acute phase of
Bartonella bacilliformis
infection is called Orroia
or carrion fever, while
the chronic phase is
called Verruga perroiana.
Infections occur at the
high-altitude Andean valleys
of Peru and in parts of
Ecuador and Colombia, where
outbreaks can occur that
involve thousands of cases.
It is transmitted by the bite
of the sandfly. Incubation
is 3 to 12 weeks, after
which infected persons have
fever, weakness, myalgia,
and arthralgias. This acute
phase is commonly associated
with a severe hemolytic
anemia that may involve
up to 80% of erythrocytes.
Those with chronic
infection experience Verruga
Peruana, a rash that is
also termed Peruvian warts.
Diagnosis is by blood
culture or peripheral
smear. Those who are treated
have a good prognosis,
but untreated, it is
associated with a mortality
rate of 90%. Acute
infection is treated with
serprofloxacin and
ceftriaxone. Chronic
infection is treated with
rifampin or streptomycin.
Skin and soft tissue signs
are an important part of
the diagnosis of Bartonella
infection. A papule or
nodule at the site of cat
scratch or bite associated with
subsequent regional
lymphadenopathy, as seen on the
top right, is characteristic
of cat scratch disease.
Bacillary angiomatosis
caused by Bartonella henselae
or Bartonella quintana is a
condition that occurs only
in the severely immune
suppressed, for example, in those
living with advanced AIDS.
It is caused by capillary
proliferation that results
in cutaneous papules and
nodules. This appearance
is very similar to that of
Kaposi's sarcoma, which
is also seen in severely
immunosuppressed persons.
Therefore, the diagnosis is made by
biopsy of the lesions,
which shows neutrophilic
infiltrates, lump endothelial
cells, termed epithelioid cells,
and basophilic aggregates
of Bartonella organisms.
PCR can also be performed
on tissue, and the
organism can be isolated
from blood cultures.
An example of bacillary
angiomatosis is
shown in the middle
picture on the right.
Verruga peruana is the
chronic eruptive phase of
Carrion's disease caused by
Bartonella bacilliformis.
It is due to localized
angioplastic hyperplasia,
or capillary ***********,
that results in blood
-filled vascular nodules
called verrugas. An
example is shown in the
picture on the bottom right.
The next bacteria we'll
talk about is the Borrelia.
They are a class
of Spirochete that
includes also Treponema
and Leptospira.
Although they are officially
gram-negative, they don't
stain well and require
special methods such as dark
field or fluorescent
microscopy for visualization.
Examples are shown at
right. They have a corkscrew
or spiral morphology.
They have a fagella,
so they are very motile
in liquid phase as well
as in tissue. They are
fastidious and require
very specific growth
requirements in culture.
Transmission is by the
bite of ticks or lice, and
rodents and birds act as
reservoirs. Although the
most recent count is about
12 different Borrelia species
that cause Lyme disease,
we will focus on Borrelia
burgdorferi since it is
by far the most common.
We will also use Borrelia
miomotoi as an example of
a cause of relapsing fever,
although you can see other
species that cause relapsing
fever on this slide.
Borrelia burgdorferi is
the agent of Lyme disease.
It is geographically
distributed in the Northeast
and Central East Coast
and Midwest of the
United States, although
that distribution is
enlarging. And it also
occurs throughout Europe.
There are about half a million
cases every year in the
United States, and that
number has been increasing
every year. It is also
probably vastly underreported.
There are approximately
200,000 cases
diagnosed in europe every
year it is transmitted
by the exodes or the
deer tick the incubation
period is three to
thirty days but may be
as short as one to three
days in some persons
stage one is the erythema
migrans rash that
may be associated with
fever and constitutional
symptoms but may not
be in many persons.
Stage two is early
dissemination and stage
three is the late stage
and we will get into
these stages in more
detail on a later slide.
Complications of Lyme
disease include arthritis,
meningitis,
cardiac conduction
abnormalities, as well
as co-infections with
other agents that are
associated with the
same Ixodes deer tick.
The diagnosis is made
clinically in those
in endemic areas who
have erythema migrans.
In those in which the
diagnosis is in question,
there is a two-step
serology method, first
ELISA and then a
confirmatory Western blot.
The organism can
also be visualized
on a wet mount dark field.
The prognosis is
usually excellent with
treatment, but may result
in prolonged sequelae,
such as arthritis or
fatigue in some persons
that is not associated
with active infection.
The treatment is
doxycycline or amoxicillin.
doxycycline is preferred, and
in those with CNS involvement,
ceftriaxone is used.
Borrelia miyamotoi is the cause
of hard tick relapsing fever.
The distribution is
the northeastern, mid
-Atlantic, and upper
Midwest U.S., as well
as California, Europe,
Russia, and Japan.
The disease is much less
common than Lyme disease,
although about one to
three percent of those
in endemic areas show
serologic infection.
Transmission is
also by the exodes
tick. The incubation
period is 12 to 16
days, but may be as
long as six weeks.
Clinical features include
fever, which may or may
not last separate, I'm
sorry, several days that is
separated by afebrile
periods. This is the relapse.
The fever is associated
with each relapse with
chills, headache, myologies,
and severe fatigue.
Complications include
meningoencephalitis
and co-infection
with other agents
that are transmitted
by the exodes tick.
Diagnosis is by PCR or
the anti-GLPQ antibody.
Prognosis is excellent
with treatment with
doxycycline, amoxicillin,
or ceftriaxone.
This slide shows the
geographic distribution
of Lyme disease
on the left in the
United States and
the right in Europe.
The darker colors on the
United States map show
larger numbers of infection
and you can see how
it is geographically
distributed to the northeast
and the midwest, mostly
Wisconsin and Michigan.
You have to know though
that this area is
expanding every year
both to the south and
to the west, and there
are more and more
cases diagnosed in
those areas every year.
And the stages of
Lyme disease a little
earlier, but let's go
into greater detail.
Stage one is early localized
infection that is characterized
by the erythema migrans
rash. This is a bullseye
or a target lesion that
occurs starting anywhere from
three to 30 days after the
tick bite. The center of
the rash is the site of the
tick bite, and the expanding
erythema are actually
advancing Borrelial organisms
accompanied by a lymphocyte
and macrophage infiltrate.
It is important to note
that 50% of people will not
have or miss this rash, so
many persons who are bitten by
a tick and have Lyme disease
don't actually know it.
Stage two is early
disseminated infection this
occurs days or months
after the original stage
one disease this is
characterized by an intermittent
rash usually a macular
erythematous rash
not a target lesion
accompanied by migratory
arthralgias, headache, and
sometimes Bell's palsy.
AV block and
myocardiopericarditis may
occur during this
stage, as well as a
non-symmetric
oligoarticular arthritis.
Stage 3 is late-stage
infection and occurs
months to years after stage
1. This is characterized
by an encephalopathy
with altered mood,
sleep, language, memory
loss, and brain fog.
In Europe, the most
common symptom of late
-stage infection is
acrodermatitis chronica
atrophicans. This is a
persistent inflammation
of the skin, particularly
along the extremities,
that causes atrophy
and discoloration.
so we're finished with the
bacteria in this lecture
and now we're going to
go on to the protozoa the
first of which is babesia
microti this is the causative
agent of babesiosis this
is a an illness that people
who live in the northeast
united states as well as
the midwest get from the
bite of an Ixodes deer
tick. There are about 2,000
cases per year in the U.S.
Incubation period after
the bite is one to four
weeks, after which the
patients have fever,
chills, fatigue, myalgias, and
this usually occurs
in the summer.
This can be complicated
with a hemolytic anemia,
hepatosplenomegaly,
thrombocytopenia, and because
of the transmitting vector,
the co-infection with
Lyme disease or anaplasmosis
is also possible.
The diagnosis is by blood
smear with a GIMSA stain
that shows a Maltese cross
or ring form within red
blood cells, examples of
which are shown on the right.
Diagnosis can also be
made by PCR of blood. The
prognosis is usually very
good with treatment, but
the disease can be worse
in the immune compromised
or the elderly. And in
those without a spleen, they
can have a very severe
infection that looks like
septic shock that lands
them in the intensive care
unit. This is associated
with a very poor prognosis.
Treatment is a 12
-quon and azithromycin
for moderate disease
and clindamycin
and quinine for severe disease.
you will notice that
I didn't really talk
about the life cycle
of Babesia on the last
slide that's because
we're really going to
go into the life cycle
of plasmodium species
so plasmodium is the cause
of malaria it's transmitted
by the Anopheles mosquito
and it is a severe often
fatal illness there are
about 300 million infections
worldwide about 600 000
deaths every year mostly in
children and those who are
pregnant it is an entirely
preventable and treatable
disease although drug
resistance is increasing this
slide shows the distribution
of the malaria worldwide,
as well as the work of
the WHO in decreasing and
attempting to eradicate malaria
from the world. You can
see that malaria involves
much of Africa, the sub
-Saharan regions, as well as
the tropical regions along
the western and eastern
coasts. It involves the
Indian subcontinent as well as
Southeast Asia and parts
of Latin and South America.
This slide shows the
plasmodium life cycle.
It is complicated, so we'll
try and go through it slowly.
An uninfected mosquito
takes a bite of a person.
who is infected.
That blood contains
gametocytes. It's the ********
reproductive stage of the
plasmodium. Within the mosquito,
these gametocytes
reproduce ******** to form
sporozoites. These are motile
infectious forms of plasmodium.
They travel to the salivary
glands of the mosquito
and are injected into the
person that the mosquito
bites to take another
blood meal the sporozoites
travel to the liver and in
the liver become merozoites
merozoites are daughter
parasites that are released
from ruptured cells they
infect red blood cells and
are the stage of plasmodium
that causes symptoms
within the erythrocyte the
the um Merozoites
transform into Trophozoites
these are the forms
that form the ring form
that can be seen on
the blood smear and
we'll see that on a
slide in a minute it.
Trophozoites then form
schizontes. This is the asexual
reproduction stage that
contain multiple nuclei
and divide asexually to
form many new neurozoites.
Some neurozoites then go
on to form gametocytes,
which are then transferred
to a new feeding mosquito.
there's a lot of information
on this and the next slide
you definitely do not need
to know all of it but we
will try to go over the
most important information
first of the five species of
plasmodium that infect humans
plasmodium falciparum and
nullis i are the two that
cause severe disease and
by severe disease we are
talking deadly plasmodium
malariae vivax and ovale cause
much less severe disease
or even chronic almost
benign disease so that
is the first important
distinction there's
differences in the
geographic distribution
for all of these species
plasmodium falciparum is
the most common species
which causes infection
in sub-saharan africa
plasmodium nolizai is
actually pretty rare it's
the most recent species
identified and it only
occurs in the forest
regions of Southeast Asia.
Plasmodium valeriae is the
species that has the widest
distribution. It occurs
everywhere there is valeria.
And Plasmodium vivax
is the most common
species outside of
Sub-Saharan Africa.
the incubation period is
usually somewhere from
let's say one to three weeks
although that for plasmodium
malaria is longer
sometimes more than a month
the fever pattern
is important for
the different species
of malaria you.
Valsaparium has an
irregular pattern
or may be continuous
and very high.
Nolusai has a quotidian
fever, one that recurs
every 24 hours, usually
at the same time.
Malaria is quartan
every three days, and
vivax and ovality is
tertium every 48 hours.
Like we said,
plasmodium,
falciparum, and nolici
are the most severe
forms of malaria.
Patients have chills, headache,
malaise, nausea,
vomiting, diarrhea,
a severe hemolytic anemia,
and laboratories show
an elevated LDH,
hypoglycemia, and acidosis.
Complications for falciparum
and Nolasi include
black water fever that
is caused by hemoglobin
urea. The urine is very
dark, thus the name.
The result is acute
tubulin necrosis
from the protein
causing damage to
the tubules and
acute renal failure.
Patients can also
have pulmonary edema.
In patients with
falciparum, but not
nolocyne, you can
have cerebral malaria,
which results in
coma and death.
We did mention that
plasmodium nolocyne has an
animal reservoir, and
these are macaque monkeys.
There are also some
studies that suggest
that the mortality
rate is actually higher
for nolocyne than it
is for falciparum.
the disease caused by
plasmodium malaria is much
milder and can actually become
subacute or even chronic
with a mild anemia
complication here is immune
conflict glomerulonephritis
from the chronic infection
infection from vivax and ovally
is actually termed
benign malaria
these patients have
a moderate anemia and
thrombocytopenia and in
vivax the laboratories
may show an elevated
LDH but in ovally
there is rarely a
severe illness or death.
What is very, very and
extremely important to point
out in this slide are
the relapsing and chronic
infection that can occur
due to the hypnozoite forms
of plasmodium Vibax and
ovale that infect the liver.
As we'll see on the next
slide, unless you are
treated with specific
medications for the
liver phase due to
Plasmodium Vibax and ovale,
months or years after
treatment, you
can have relapse.
the diagnosis of malaria
as well as a diagnosis of
these specific species can
be made by PCR testing there
are also rapid diagnostic
chemical tests however the
diagnostic rapid tests
are not very sensitive for
the different species and
PCR is just not available in
most of the areas in which
plasmodium infection occurs
very importantly the blood
smear is used in cases
of falciparum infection not
only to make the diagnosis
of falciparum but also to
prognosticate the patient
falciparum has the ability to
result in single
erythrocytes being infected
by multiple parasites
this is termed
high parasitemia there
are also multiple
parasitized red blood cells
on a single high power
field this is actually the
high parasitemia excuse me
which is different from malaria
5x and ovale you can see
multiple ring forms in a
single high-powered field,
as well as crescent-shaped
gametocytes in falciparum.
As we said, this is
used to prognosticate
the patient with
the higher number of
infected erythrocytes
per high-powered field
associated with a
higher risk of death.
treatment of malaria
used to be chloroquine
for the entire world but
now most areas with malaria
have falciparum that
is resistant to chloroquine
the only species that
is reliably chloroquine
sensitive is malariae
therefore the
basis of therapy is
artemisinin based
combination therapy or act
an example is
artemether lumifantrine
this is the treatment of
choice for falciparum and
nolici as they are largely
resistant to chloroquine
in in those areas of the
world that do have the
ability to do anti
-malarial resistance tests
um plasmodium vivax and
ovale ovale can be treated
with chloroquine if they
are shown to be sensitive
otherwise ACT therapy
is the rule but
remember for plasmodium
vivax and ovale we
have to follow that
therapy with primaquin
or tefenoquin to
eradicate the liver stage
Here is an example of a
slide of a blood smear of a
person infected with cosmodium
falciparum. This is a
very, very high-grade
parasitemia with many ring forms
shown in multiple
erythrocytes. You can also see
erythrocytes with multiple
ring forms within single cells.
For example, the cell
right in the middle there.
This is a very,
very poor prognosis.
The next protozoa we'll talk
about is Toxoplasma gondii.
This causes toxoplasmosis.
It's an obligate
intracellular parasite
that infects all
warm blooded animals.
It occurs worldwide,
more prevalent in
warm climates. About
one quarter of the
world's population
has been infected,
about 10% in the US.
Transmission is
from house cats,
contaminated meat or shellfish.
Cats eat infected rodents and
shed oocysts in the stool.
And humans get infected when
we clean their litter boxes.
Vertical transmission
can cause congenital
toxoplasmosis. This is a
triad of chorioretinitis,
hydrocephalus, and
intracranial calcifications.
Little babies may have
a blueberry muffin rash,
as in the above picture.
The prognosis is
variable with some children
having little effect,
others having severe
developmental disabilities
into adulthood, and some
children having chorio
-retinitis or other ocular
abnormalities as they age.
some children actually
die of this infection.
In the immune-competent
person, there is usually no
symptoms, but they may cause
fever, lymphadenopathy,
ocular disease,
rarely myocarditis,
hepatitis, and
disseminated disease.
Reactivation disease occurs
in the immune-suppressed,
For example, in persons
living with AIDS and a CD4
count less than 100 per
microliter, and in those with
solid organ or hematopoietic
stem cell transplants.
This results in cerebral
toxoplasmosis, chorio
-retinitis, and disseminated
infection that can be fatal.
The diagnosis is serum
antibody, usually an
acutely elevated IgM.
you can also see a ring
enhancing lesion on
CT or MRI of the brain
that is shown in
the right panel
of the picture on the bottom
this is very similar in
appearance to primary CNS
lymphoma in persons living
with AIDS And the usual
treatment strategy is to do
a CSF analysis to see whether
or not there is antibodies
in the CSF for toxoplasma
or cancer cells can be
detected. if no diagnosis
can be made there then
a treatment course of
pyrimethamine sulfadiazine and
trimethoprim sulfamethoxazole
is given for several
weeks to see if there is a
response in the brain
lesions if not then a brain
biopsy is performed to make
the definitive diagnosis.
Portozole we'll talk
about is Leishmania.
This occurs in
Central and South
America, Africa,
and the Middle East.
It is a blood-borne
obligate intracellular
parasite that is transmitted
by the sand fly bite.
There are more than
20 species that infect
humans, but we will
just look at a few.
The sand flight that's
infected by a blood meal
from rodents, dogs, and
foxes bites a human and then
injects the human with
the promastigote stage.
These motile promastigotes
infect macrophages and
transform into amotile
amastigotes, which multiply
within the macrophages and
cause disease. The infection
usually results in highly
disfiguring ulcers,
but can also cause fatal
internal organ involvement.
There are several
different forms of
leishmaniasis, depending
on how well the
parasite grows at
different temperatures.
Their cutaneous
form, the parasite,
grows well at
lower temperatures.
The bite of the sandfly
results in a skin ulcer
and an eventual scar
after about one year.
This may be diffuse
in immune-compromised
individuals. The
diagnosis is made by an
ulcer scraping that
shows macrophages filled
with amastigotes the
mucocutaneous form
is characterized by a
skin ulcer that heals very
quickly but is followed by
mucous membrane ulceration
sometimes septal nasal
septal erosion and these
may have secondary bacterial
infection and these
result in extremely disfiguring
ulcers and scars the
species that causes
this is Leishmania
brithuliensis and the
diagnosis is again made by
ulcer scraping a more
severe form of the disease
is called visceral
leishmaniasis or kala azar
This is characterized
by organ involvement.
Patients have fever, diarrhea,
anemia, hepatosplenomegaly,
reticuloendothelial
spread, and it is fatal if
untreated. The most
common species causing
visceral leishmaniasis
is Leishmania donovani.
Leishmania donovani can cause
all three forms, cutaneous,
mucocutaneous, and visceral,
but it is pretty rare
to see it cause cutaneous
and mucocutaneous disease.
Diagnosis is by serology
or liver and spleen biopsy,
where you'll see macrophages
filled with amastic
oats. The last form of
leishmaniasis is post
-colazar dermal leishmaniasis,
which is an active form
of infection that occurs
during or after treatment,
and it may become chronic
despite treatment.
Treatment is with
stilbogluconate, which is
obtained in the United
States from the CDC
if you diagnose this
in a returned traveler.
Amphotericin B and other
treatments are available,
but you are definitely going
to call the CDC if you have
a patient that you suspect
or confirm has leishmaniasis
for consultation the
last protozoa we'll talk
about is tripatosoma there
are two species cruzi and
brucei the cruzi occurs
in rural areas from south
texas to south america
the cases have also been
reported from california
arizona tennessee louisiana
Missouri, Mississippi,
and Arkansas, although
there hasn't been a case
in the United States since
2019 to my knowledge.
This is the causative
agent of Chagas disease.
The transmission is
from the regiovid or
kissing bug, and the
animal reservoir are dogs,
armadillos, opossum,
and other mammals.
Patients have fever,
malaise, and lymphadenopathy,
but actually most persons
infected are asymptomatic.
The shagoma is a
indurated red rash
at the site of the
bite of the regimen
bug an example is
shown on the right
and Romagna's sign is a
periorbital edema and a rash
that is shown in the
far right picture
the other clinical
features include
the irreversible triad
of mega esophagus
megacolon and dilated
cardiomyopathy with
or without right
bundle branch block.
This is a feared result
of this infection
as these patients are
severely debilitated
and have a shortened
life expectancy.
Diagnosis is by
serology or blood smears
that show the
tripomastigote form And
treatment is with
Nifertimox or Vensnidazole.
Trypanosoma brucei is the cause
of African sleeping sickness.
There are two
subspecies, Gambians in
West Africa and
Rhodosiens in East Africa.
The map is shown on the right.
the transmission is from a
bite of the tsetse fly and
the reservoir for gambians
is uh usually domestic uh
farm animals such as pigs
or cattle and that from uh
roads rhodesians is from
domestic or wild animals such
as the bush back bush back
these patients have a hard
indurated painful red ulcer
at the bite that heals within
two weeks. They then have
an early hemolymphatic
stage, which is characterized
by an enlarged posterior
cervical lymph node that is
termed winter bottom sign.
And this is followed
by a systemic phase,
which is slowly
progressive relapsing
fever, headache,
dizziness, and wasting.
And then a late CNS stage,
the sleeping sickness stage,
which is lethargy, behavioral
changes, ataxia,
slurred speech,
coma, and eventually
death. the only
difference between
rhodesians and gambians
is that persons who
are infected with
rhodesians is a much quicker
progression than gambians
this occurs in patients
with Rodeciense weeks or
months from fever through
systemic and late CNS
infection within weeks to
months. A diagnosis for
trypanosomal bucei is a GIMSA
blood smear that reveals
trypanomastigotes or a
lymph node aspirate or CSF
analysis. And treatment is
with pantamidine or cerumin
for systemic infection
and melarsoprol for cns
infection we're going to
talk about two viruses the
first show of whist which
is zika this is a fairly
new we discovered virus at
first was seen in 2007 in
the pacific islands but
it's now distributed to
south and central america
central in west africa
southeast asia and there have
been cases in florida and
texas although i believe
the last case was in 2019
this is a flaviviridae which
are positive send single
-stranded enveloped rna
viruses Transmission is by
the Aedes aegypti or Aedes
albopictus mosquitoes.
There's also perinatal,
gestational, ****** blood
transfusion and solid organ
transplant transmission.
most persons infected are
asymptomatic but those
with symptoms have fever
headache arthralgias myalgias
pruritus maculopapular
rash and conjunctivitis
similar to other inflatable
viruses the real concern
here is the congenital
Zika syndrome which was
really uh revealed in an
outbreak in brazil in 2015
where up to 4 000 children
were born with microcephaly
this was a horrible outbreak
um this usually occurs
when infection occurs in
the mother in the first
trimester uh the prognosis
for these children is
extremely poor with a severe
developmental delay with
many of the children passing
away soon after birth.
Zika virus infection can
be complicated by Guillain
-Barre syndrome, and there
is the possibility with or
for co-infection with other
orthoflaviviruses, which
are what the flavoviruses
are now called, that are
transmitted by the same Aedes
mosquito and there have been
cases of co-infection with
dengue and chikungunya.
Diagnosis should be
suspected in those with a
travel history or those
living in endemic areas
and can be made with a
PCR, ELISA or serology.
There is no specific treatment.
The second virus we'll
talk about is SARS-CoV-2.
You all know this as
the cause of COVID-19.
This is distributed
globally and is a
very common infection
that occurs in
multiple time periods
throughout the year.
this was such a global
distribution that
when the pandemic first
started there were
cases in Antarctica within
the first few months
of 2020 the pandemic
began where it was
officially made a pandemic
at that time but the
first infections were noted
in 20 at the end of 2019.
The virus is a Coronaviridae,
an envelope positive
sense single-stranded RNA
virus. The spike protein on
the envelope binds the ACE2
receptor on human cells.
Transmission is mostly
aerosol, but also
droplet, less so by contact
or contaminated surfaces.
It is human-to-human
and also can be
transmitted to domesticated
animals, zoo animals.
There are cases of
mink and white-tailed
deer transmitting the
disease to humans.
The incubation period
is three to seven days.
Many people are
asymptomatic when infected.
Those who have symptoms,
it's usually fever, cough,
shorts of breath, but there
are also lots of other
symptoms that you can have,
including a viral pneumonia.
If you're not immune to the
disease, in other words,
you haven't had SARS-CoV-2
infection or vaccination,
you are at risk still of
having severe illness.
complications include a
late inflammatory phase,
which has been termed a
cytokine storm that looks
like septic shock. There's
also the possibility
of co-infection with
other respiratory viruses,
specifically influenza
and RSV during the upper
respiratory tract season and
patients can also have a post
-viral bacterial pneumonia
up to 40 to 50 percent of
people who are infected
and infected may experience
long covid which has
various definitions but is
essentially prolonged symptoms
more than three months after
infection this includes
children who are infected.
Diagnosis is made by a
rapid antigen or PCR.
Treatment is with nirmatrelvir,
ritonavir primarily.
Remdesivir is less effective,
and there is a newer treatment
for the late inflammatory
phase, we usually
do give steroids,
but steroids given in
the early phase of
acute infection are
actually associated
with worsening disease.
Prevention is, of course,
vaccination.
And that's it. That was a lot
of information
in 24, 25 slides.
Here is a summary of all
of the organisms we talked
about. I know these are
difficult to remember, and
most of those names are
very difficult to pronounce.
Please do not hesitate to
contact me if you have any
questions about the
information in this lecture in
summary uh the epidemiology
incidence and geographic
distribution of vector
-borne disease is evolving
knowledge helps clinicians
recognize and manage these
emerging pathogens and
expert consultation for
emerging pathogens exists
at the state and federal
levels thank you so much
for reviewing and good luck.
Please do give us feedback.
We really do value
your opinion to make
things better. Thank
you so much and have a
great rest of your day.